[Music]
it was
find everybody involved find them now
[Music]
we knew there was an individual that was
responsible for all the logistical
movement of marijuana and then cocaine
but
we weren't sure who he was
so we raided house after house after
house
one name pops up and he continued to pop
up
chapel guzman
people called him chapel which is a
shorty
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
he was five foot six guy who starved out
as a little kid selling oranges on the
side of the road down in sinaloa
at that time he was well down the ranks
in the sinaloa cartel
he was a border rat
[Music]
he knew virtually every corner of the
border where was the most highly
patrolled area
where were desolate areas
where was the most valuable part of it
in terms of cocaine trafficking
cartel bosses recognized that he was
extremely smart
he was years ahead of anybody else that
ever came into the drug smuggling scene
the flip side to that is he was also
a ruthless cold calculated
killer
30 guys were used to dig this tunnel
night and day for months and months they
kept them locked up in a house
and the cartel wanted to keep it secret
so bad
and they were worried that somebody
would talk about it so they executed
them all and dumped them into a well
so basically all the tunnel duggars dug
their own grave for the cartel
[Music]
it was a gold mine for him kilo of
cocaine back in those days about
24 000 dollars a kilo this tunnel
probably would have ran who knows one
truck a day
[Music]
two trucks a day
three maybe
[Music]
chapel went from the little guy over
here in douglas
to captain in the cartel
he was such a rising star
[Music]
chapo was nicknamed by the colombians
el rapido because he was so fast in
moving the
cocaine
he didn't share his methods of
transportation
but he was a genius
and troublemaker
[Music]
you